[Music]
okay so we're going to go to the
carbocon
and
we faced this before
all right guys so we've we faced this
before
and one of the ideas of this move is to
meet bishop f5 with this move knight to
d4
now not a lot of people actually know
that
so we're still going to go bishop f5
here and make the typical car con
okay guys let's switch to the game
please i
i think that i've said all that i wanted
to say on this topic
so what's the move here the move here is
e6 yeah the move here is e6 and
obviously the reason is
to open up the bishop and to prepare
the move c5 which is you know i've
explained this the
the rationale behind this before you're
essentially trying to
um knock down essentially trying to
contest white spawn chain that's the the
zen of the carbocon
okay so bishop d3 um i guess moving on
we're not talking about the round two
you're welcome to tune in to the youtube
and watch it i want to focus on this
game okay
um so
yeah well it's it's the most watched
game i'm sorry but it's the most watched
game in chess history for all the wrong
reasons
and um that's not something that i
necessarily i mean it's
it's it's interesting but it's not
necessarily something i want to just
like celebrate
okay so should we take the bishop what
should we do here
what should we do here
so we could trade the bishops here but
we could also enforce the concept of
trading on our own terms
so we can try to make him take on
f5 yes i like bishop g6 actually i love
bishop g6
because if he takes our bishop which he
probably is going to
we take with the h1 and when he castles
he's going to have to deal with
the opening of the h file okay so what
do we do what do we do now what's the
sequence of events here what do we do
next
what do we do next
so the next move is c5 we need to follow
through
on our main idea the move c5
accomplishes two specific things it
it puts pressure on the d4 pawn and it
also
opens up the c6 square for r knight
which is super good square
we put more pressure on this pawn rookie
he's playing pretty well and now we can
kind of play
as if it were the french and in the
french
you basically put pressure on this d4
pawn until it cracks
how do we do that yeah so f6
is premature because it opens up the e
file and that's in his favor
bingo queen b6 is a great move here yes
very nice
and he's cracked so he's tunnel visioned
this pawn
without realizing of course that he also
drops this spawn
that's often what happens in these kinds
of situations
because people are less experienced with
these kinds of positions they tend to
tunnel vision
when they tunnel vision they start
dropping a bunch of pawns right or they
do something like bishop e3
without paying attention to the other
side of the board okay rook b1
so i'm not really commenting this i'm
just taking all of his pawns one by one
we're now three pawns up and we've
ruined isn't okay so he's
he's just blundering stuff here all
right so take stakes
and now we're up a piece and we're
basically winning together one thing
that we have to be a little bit careful
about here
is is obviously the fact that we haven't
developed our kingside pieces we have to
do so
efficiently but it's not like he can
do anything to our king it's not like he
can really exploit this
so we're just gonna have to be a little
bit careful about that
we're just gonna have to be a little bit
careful about that
yeah our king is open what should white
play to avoid losing the full house yeah
i'll i'll definitely talk about that
after the game
i'll definitely talk about that after
the game
[Music]
okay so we can play bishop b4 but i like
bishop c5 because that
that hits it where it hurts on the f2
square
yeah so you can find more of the
speedrun on youtube my youtube channel
will eventually contain all of these
speedruns
but it contains most of the speedruns
already
i'd be honored if you subscribe to my
youtube
we now cross 150 000 subs
aiming toward 200 000 that would be
awesome
yeah so knight h69 f5 is great obviously
but yeah yeah so i'll talk about the
logistics of what he could have done in
just a second let's see what he plays
okay
yeah it will be a long journey but
hopefully it'll be instructive
the bottom line is that i'm trying to
make
as much instructive content as i can for
as many people as i can
and you know i want to help as many
people as possible get past the beginner
level so
it's a it's an ambitious goal but
um you know the speed run is my first
really big project and he just resigns
which is
fair which is fair
uh because he's just that lost so
yeah so okay so this move knight to d4
is something that people at this level
don't really play
and the idea is to attack the bishop but
it's not
only to attack the bishop after bishop
g6
how can white actually follow up on this
what do we what is what is what it's
supposed to do here
i'm not playing the wrong account guys
but people need to realize and i'm gonna
be very
straightforward here a lot of people are
like well where is the latest youtube
video my
i don't have a whole team that works for
me i'm just one guy
and i have one editor his name is clyde
he's an m
he's a vip on on this stream he works
extremely hard he puts out a video every
day
i don't have 18 people working for me so
we're doing things at the pace
um that we that we can manage
and everything will eventually be out on
youtube but
i don't have four channels and it is
what it is the pace is what it is so
that's just what it's going to be um and
that's how it's always going to be
because you know i'm just a dude like
i'm not
ever going to have like a whole
entourage behind me
even if that means sacrificing a little
bit of speed
all right because i like that personal
touch i like people to just know that
it's just
just me just maybe one more guy and
that's that's just always been my style
yeah thank you guys i appreciate it
clyde is definitely a hero
okay um so this is an annoying move
because it basically disrupts
it disrupts uh a black's development
makes it harder
to get this bishop out and it and it
it makes the king weaker um but the move
here is actually queen d6 like black
should respond with queen d6 here
because that attacks e6
and after ef7 bishop f7 you can actually
just go e5 you can control the center
this is not an easy move to see this
move queen d6 it requires
kind of a zen approach to the position
because panicking
and taking the pawn actually plays into
white's hands because after knight takes
e6
you have to move the queen then he takes
the bishop then you have to take with
the king who
you don't really want to take with the
king because now you can't castle
anymore and you don't have a dark sword
bishop that's not great
so that's just something that we had to
bear in mind he goes d4 instead
e6 bishop b3 bishop g6 so i really like
this move
now there's a couple of alternative ways
of playing this position
and you guys are pointing them out you
don't have to play c5
first of all you can get the knight over
to f5 via h6 that's a typical karokon
idea
um you can also go knight to d7 and then
knight to e7 and then c5 and knight to
c6
so c5 is not a mandatory move for this
early but it really does make it easier
for black to develop
because now like you're essentially
orienting your blade toward attacking
this pawn
so the reason f6 isn't good here is
because you're offering white to open up
the center
the question of who does this favor who
does this benefit right interesting
it benefits white because if you look at
this position
very carefully you'll notice that the
rook now can just take on e6 with check
so on a more general level
white has castled and black is not
castled and when you have this disparity
the fact that the center is closed is
actually really good for black
because it allows you to keep your king
in the center
with impunity without it being punished
right so you have to think of things in
the on this kind of
general level i'm not castled white is
castle so
if i keep the center closed then i can
get away with that
all right queen b6 bishop e3
and queen takes b2 so instead of this he
should have probably gone
something like knight to a3 that would
be one good way
of ensuring that a spawn were to be
defended because then he could
drop his knight away back to c2 thank
you killer cat for the stuff
and that makes it very hard for me to
actually
win the d4 pawn i would have probably
gone knight h695
and black has a very nice position all
of my pieces
are focused on pressuring the spawn but
white can keep this pawn alive for the
time being
yeah so you basically keep applying
pressure there's no reason to take
until you absolutely have to um
so let's play c6 let's play carl
and we've been focusing mostly on
on the karo khan um with the black
pieces because that is like the og
solid opening okay let's play cd oh and
another 25
god damn girl damn girl incredible
another 25. holy smokes
holy smokes all right
i don't know what to say seven for one
other than you are a beast
okay now knight c3 is already an
inaccuracy
knight c3 is already an inaccuracy
um and
why is that the case yeah i usually i'll
turn the notifications off because of
this
mean support why is that the case
because so knight c3 is a very natural
developing move that a lot of people
play automatically but it blocks the c
pawn and i'll talk about this more after
the game
it it blocks the scene you might be like
well why is it important that white
blocks the sea pun what does that c pawn
do for me
well the c pawn can be pushed to c4
that's the pawn on variation or it can
be pushed to c3 in order to defend
before so on a basic level
this pawn on d4 is very much weakened
and as you guys will see as the game
develops that's going to become very
important so let's develop our pieces
i'm just going to develop knight c6 9 f6
now again i don't expect this to be
intuitive because you look at this and
say well the queen's defending the pawn
the knight can develop and defend the
pawn
but defending a pawn with pieces is not
the same as defending a pawn with
another pawn
when you defend a pawn with pieces by
definition that
that gives the pieces an assignment that
they may not want to have
and we have many ways to put pressure on
this pawn
thank you for the 2000 okay so let's go
knight f6
now where should this bishop go assuming
he allows it
where should this bishop unsee it go on
the next move
okay this is a good move but where
should this go
yeah bishop g4 with what aim
is the aim just to pin the night well
the aim is to pin the knight
but it's also potentially to actually
trade in order to soften
up his defense of the d4 pawn so
our plan in the early going is going to
be to develop our pieces a but b
to do so with an eye toward pressuring
the d4 pawn that's all there is to it
one of the great things about the
karakan is that it helps you practice
good peace development and generally the
plans are are quite simple
we're not doing anything crazy everybody
in the room
all 2500 of you should be able to
understand why
i'm developing the way that i am yeah so
when do you exchange for the night well
you would exchange for the night when
there's a necessity of doing so
now as long as you're pinning the night
you're not in a hurry to take the knight
but he's gone queen d3 that's actually a
very good move
queen d3 unpins the knight now is that
important well that kind of is important
because if we just go e6 if we go about
our business
then where is this night going to go
and if you see this move then you will
understand
that this is a very unpleasant
possibility 95
and now he has a pin of his own so now
is when we take on f3
so the short answer to your question is
you make a commitment move like this
when you absolutely need to when that
when when you can't delay any longer
procrastination interest is a good thing
but you don't want to over procrastinate
or you're going to miss your opportunity
okay so we can't take we're pinned we
don't need to play a6 that's another
move which
i think a lot of you guys maybe want to
play intuitively
but i don't necessarily want to
encourage him to take his
to take the knight i'm not afraid of
this pin why because i've got a pawn
that defends the knight and once i
castle
uh the tooth falls out organically right
okay so he takes i take he's
actually helping me okay so knight takes
d5 and he just collapses
i'm not sure what he has in mind here
but this just blunders a piece
and it actually doesn't even matter what
we take with
we can take either with the queen or
with the knight sorry we can take either
with a queen or with a pawn
um but in the interest of playing solid
chess in the interest of playing
uh you know good positional chess
let's take with the queen to encourage
the queen trade which he basically has
to go for because if he doesn't
he's going to lose one of these things
simplifying
thank you so much evil fair appreciate
your support
yeah so we're just going to take back
the queen
yeah well if queen d3 then we take on g2
right gm shadow also like i would have
considered that but the knight was
hanging so it's just much simpler to
just take the knight
yeah this guy's i mean he's gonna he's
gonna get banned
okay yeah i'm in bay area so it's 12.50
for me
okay so he takes the queen we take
um
so feels like you're weakening your pawn
structure after the queen trade
now yes but it doesn't matter
the point is i'm up a piece and
he doesn't have the firepower to attack
this pawn on d5 if that makes sense
all right why doesn't he have the
firepower well he doesn't have a knight
anymore
the only piece that could even
hypothetically attack the spawn
is this bishop which could potentially
swing to b3
and we could neutralize that move by
playing what
or we could castle short or with an eye
toward defending the pawn on d5 at the
same time
we could do what we could castle long
and i think some people might be
disawaited from this move because
of because of the fact that
you know i feel like there's this notion
that you shouldn't cast along in the end
game
but that that is that's not necessarily
the case this is a great move because it
keeps the rook protecting the pawn
c4 is a good thought but he just
blunders the pawn
and now the game is basically over
okay um
now the game is basically over okay so
he takes on d5 so should we
take back what should we do here
it all depends on the position
no don't let me trick you guys this
bishop is hanging
we just take it well
i wouldn't um rush to
okay so now all we really need to do
let's involve the rook
into the game look he8 yeah
okay he's helping us okay so d6 i mean
he's got a
nakedly obvious idea of going d7
which we should prevent with one mode
now i know a lot of people would like
take the pawn here
and i spoke about this in a five minute
speed run like
you shouldn't give away pieces for no
good reason
when you can preserve them instead you
should do what
yeah just kinky seven or rook d it was
also good but i like involving the king
and then we take on d6
so the rule for winning up a lot of
material is
you should only give up some of the
material if that
you know if that simplifies the task or
eliminates counter play
but you shouldn't be trigger happy when
it comes to giving up parts of your
material because before you know it
you could end up giving up too much of
your material
so i feel like i've maybe been a little
bit misleading
when i've told people to to give up
parts of their material okay so b6 i
mean you can go rookie it doesn't even
matter what we do here we can just take
all the spawns i want to freeze i want
to freeze his pawns
so so he doesn't cause me any trouble
here
but it really doesn't matter and he
resigns so the server resets
pretty soon i'm going to answer more
questions and it does
um so okay this was a pretty simple game
now knight c3
uh i explained i think pretty clearly
why this is an inaccuracy it's not a
huge mistake
but it is an inaccuracy after which
white is basically fighting for equality
all right same here simon thanks for
stopping in
have a great night my man yeah so knight
c3
blocks the c2 pawn and
the reason that is important is because
he's got a pawn on d4 and in a
way that you can think about this is
that this pawn now essentially becomes
isolated it in effect becomes isolated
because this knight
blocks its only potential defense with
another pawn does that make sense
so c4 here is absolutely a move
and that's the pawn of attack that's a
legitimate line
but the more solid line that i recommend
to my students who are on the beginner
end
are is bishop d3 and then c3 in order to
protect the spawn with another pawn
then this knight can develop eventually
via d2
okay yeah raj skin or i do
quite a bit actually so knight c3 and i
guess it is an influence on my narration
style knight f3
knight f6 okay developing we should be
five bishop g4 this is where you guys
should ask questions
if you have them uh
and queen d3 that's a good move now
if white had played h3 here's a
instructive question for you guys
should we take on f3 or should we drop
the bishop back to h5
so yeah the reason that uh bishop d3 is
good
if c3 immediately then you allow sorry
you allow the bishop to come to f5
which is a nice prime real estate and on
broadway
you don't want to let that bishop
develop there so you go bishop d3 first
um so i just want to see what people are
thinking this is really interests me
okay so most people are saying drop back
so i actually kind of tricked some of
you i think you should take
so as i said earlier the rule for
deciding
when you want to take and when you want
to procrastinate is
you want to procrastinate until the
point of no return until the point at
which your opponent
can actually permanently prevent you
from
doing what you want to do and
if you drop the bishop back then why
does the move g4
attacking a bishop but everybody should
understand this this is what i want to
make clear
and guess what you've lost the
possibility of taking the knight
now why is that a problem why is that a
problem what can i do to you here
very unpleasant move the whole point was
to pin the knight and eventually take it
but in addition
we go 95 and let me make me loma because
this is not winning for white this is
just very unpleasant but everybody
should see that
rook c8 you have to play then maybe h4h5
comes in
this becomes very very unpleasant and
this bishop actually becomes
the instrument of black's demise whereas
it was supposed to be the instrument of
white's demise right you were supposed
to use this bishop to take white's
knight now this bishop might get trapped
all right now the reason i think some
people
don't see this is because you've been
conditioned to think
not to put words in anybody's mouth but
you've been conditioned to think
that this move is very weakening and we
want to induce it
and you want to try to stay away from
these kind of categorical thoughts
because
g4 is a very weakening move but it's a
lot more weakening of white's castle and
even when white's castled it i can give
you
many situations when g4 is perfectly
justified it is not as weakening of a
move
as some people make it out to be so you
have to be really careful
sometimes it's good to induce this move
you gotta make sure
that you're not giving your opponent a
big initiative okay so we actually would
want to take this knight
and play as we did in the game so e6
bishop d6 castles
maybe eventually queen b6 to increase
the pressure on the pawn
okay so queen d3 we take that's why we
took
e6 and obviously knight takes d5 just
gave up the game immediately
um yeah so there's plenty of positions
we're taking on g4 is good
but generally when white castles um
generally when white castles okay
so instead what should white do here
now what should i do in a position like
this let's say you got this position
before the server resets so
yeah so essentially i would consider
castling long
although this position is very dangerous
for white
because this pawn is very weak and we've
also got the semi open c file
so you guys should see that this is very
very dangerous
now castling short is not good because
you blunder the pawn
but what i would do and let me let me
illustrate the logic here
what's the biggest problem in white's
position
that's a question i want you guys to
answer and then i'm going to walk you
through my logic here what's the biggest
problem in white's position
that's it's a pawn on d4 right we know
that it's the weak pawn on d4
so how should we defend a weak pawn well
preferably we should defend it with
another pawn
well what's stopping us from playing c3
well it's the knight on c3
what's stopping this from going 92 and
then c3 there is something stopping us
there is something stopping us from
going 92 what is it
now if you had your tactical if you had
a tactical um
x-ray vision on you would see that the
queen the bishop is undefended
you have a puzzle rush motif queen a5
check this doesn't win the bishop
but it forces knight c3 and this is a
disaster
so what preliminary action could we take
in order to eliminate this possibility
and it's not ideal to do this but
desperate situations call for desperate
measures
we could begin by so
you guys are trying to artificially
solve it thank you for the 1500
you guys are trying to artificially
solve the problem of queen a5 but
remember
what black's threatening to take the
pawn don't lose sight of that
you take the knight first then you play
92 and then you play c3
yes so i think that this would have
limited
black's advantage quite a bit all right
because this both
keeps the pawn defended in the meantime
and eliminates
the possibility queen a5 is still
possible but it doesn't do anything
and white is doing okay here okay so
that's the logic
that would have led me to take on c6
this also
just by virtue of its of its
you know by virtue of the move itself it
lessens the pressure on the d4 pump
because the knight was actually putting
pressure on it
okay so that's uh
that's an example of simple positional
logic
okay so that's all there is to it all
right the server is going to reset any
second so i can't start a new game okay
it's already resetting
yeah um i'm not trying to you know
pretend that this is very complicated
this is actually quite straightforward
could you go into rook placement
all right so tips on protecting the dark
square bishop and the king's indian
yeah but that's actually fine super neon
you you shouldn't be too
too afraid of defending that bishop
um but one thing i can teach you guys a
sexy car gifting a tier three to
salamander
is in the kings and see this is why
they're this is why it's so important
to understand the ideas of an opening so
in the sameish variation of the king's
indian just to give you guys an example
there is a very cool trick and i'm quite
sure that
a lot of you could benefit from this
trick let's say we have this position
many times white plays the move bishop
h6 in order to try to trade
the dark squared bishop but in a
position of this
sort this is a tactical error who knows
the refutation here
who knows what the refutation is
it's knight takes e4 yeah i take c4 this
attacks the queen so we have to take the
knight
and now a queen check forks the bishop
and the king
now we take on h6 and not only have we
preserved the bishop but we are now up
upon
so knowing this idea will arm you with
the opportunity to not only set traps
but also to
you know to win a lot of games like this
so
imagine assembling a
compilation of like 15 of these types of
ideas
imagine how much better you'll be at the
opening that you normally play a
thousand bets from sexy car thank you
so that's just one small example of that
another um on the topic of
on the topic of preserving your dark
sword bishop
let me show you guys a game since the
server is down
that i gave to my students recently
so i gave this to a pretty wide range of
students
who are pretty high rated but i think
everybody can understand the concept
here
and i quite like the games of akiba
rubinstein
to illustrate various positional ideas
so let me find it if you just give me a
second here
um this is ruben stein against duress
carlsbad 2011 duros was
a pretty good player he was like top 10
in in the early early 1900s i think
so this guy was this guy was good um
but here he made a very instructive
conceptual mistake so
we just have sort of a position it's
black to play
and clearly white has
quite a big space advantage you know why
does a big space advantage white's got
more of a center
we have the question of where to put the
knight
which is something that i think a lot of
players
struggle with you know this question
where do you put a piece like how do you
determine what square
to retreat to or do you even retreat
and this is a great example of how chess
has evolved
because duress by all accounts quite
quickly
played the move 97 which is like the
most tempting retreat
and he got corrupt i mean he didn't get
crushed he just got positionally
outplayed
he never got off got out of the gates
again i mean his position just got more
and more passive
rubenstein played a brilliant positional
game to outplay him
but duras never got out of the gates
thank you azakir baitar
and shadow you're suggesting knight
before
and i'm gonna say something which i
don't mean
negatively and i don't mean it
condescendingly this
is a good the spirit of this move is
good
but it's kind of pseudoactive and
pseudoactive moves are very tempting
because it looks like the knight does
more than before
but remember that pieces are very
fragile things
and that means that they're very easy to
kick around with pawns
so that's why the concept of outpost is
so important
why can just play a3 you have to drop
the knight to a6 now you might say okay
i get it
but maybe i want to get the knight to c5
so what should i do here
what should white do here
yeah just b4 and you've got a big
problem the knight is
permanently out of the game so
that's um that's an issue and so the
correct move as many of you have
indicated is to sack the pawn with
knight t4
the bishop takes d4 e takes d4 now you
can't take with the knight because the
queen is pinned so you have to take with
the queen
and the job is not yet done what you
have to notice here is that this bishop
on fa does not have any role
um but it's got a role to play because
the queen and the rook are on the same
diagonal
and so the move g6 here gives black good
compensation for the pawn
very good compensation for the phone
white is a slightly better objectively
but from a practical perspective this is
great for black so
i mean this is a slight detour i was
asked about the
role of the bishop but this is a good
example of
understanding that peace activity
particularly the activity of your
bishops
is worth a lot more than a pawn in most
cases
yeah you can take the knight on f3
actually but you don't have to i mean
this light scored bishop is not a bad
piece it's putting some pressure on the
knight you can take on f3 later
if you need to but i wouldn't
necessarily rush it
okay so players have become more active
players have have become more tall like
in their
instincts and that's how chess should be
played according to modern engines
um okay so let me see
the server is still down which means i
can take more questions
i can take more questions
doesn't the queen move away yeah i mean
the queen should move away
but you're not just trying to win the
exchange you're trying to activate the
bishops
and then the play becomes a lot easier
maybe you can get the queen out you can
get the rook to c8
you've got a very active game
when do you build center compared to
going flank well
there's no general answer to that
question
it's it's more a matter of uh you know
understanding that
you normally have to have a
well-protected center before you start a
flank attack
but how well protected a center has to
be depends also on what your opponent
does
so it is it's it really depends i think
but you should always err on the side of
having your center too well protected
is it bad to play queen's game but
almost exclusively as white no in fact
i'll i'm happy to play it in the next
game although
i'll make a small exception to the speed
run rule and i'll play the queen's
gambit
it is certainly not a bad idea to play
it as your main opening
queen's gambit is considered to be
essentially one of the best openings
available
as long as you feel like you're getting
exposed to a variety of different kinds
of positions that's fine
and you know you can study it and you
can get better at it
i think that um there's nothing
inherently wrong with that if that's
what you're asking
okay um
now to tie this into
something i was talking about earlier
this book that i mentioned
uh by john watson's secrets of modern
chess strategy
is a phenomenal book that sounds a
little bit boring but it's actually a
phenomenal book
and it's a little bit misleading because
it's almost a historical book
on how chess thinking has evolved
so like the chapters the center and
development minorities majorities and
past pawns
the evolution of the iqp those radical
rooks
overview i mean there are some amazing
juicy passages
and games in in this book so
i actually think if you're interested in
how chess thinking has evolved
and this is also a very instructive book
you should absolutely
consider reading it john watson is a
super interesting author in general he's
got some other interesting books which i
haven't read
[Music]